can I have more of the tequila ones yeah
that's what fine oh you're letting eat
[Music]
we are here to taste test some different
gummies and the alcohol that it may or
may not taste like I like gummy candy
because it is delicious and it's the
best kind of candy candy with alcohol I
think it's just genius everyone needs a
little bit of drinking during the day to
get them through it and might as well
try it with the gummy is I'm hoping the
views are more sugary than alcoholic
that they have like like a whisper of
alcohol are you ready to try the candies
already okay let's do it
that is very Sheree I can taste the
Bourbon mm-hmm but what's not bad how
many do you need to have a shot of this
I'm done nope oh come to it we taste it
look like I'm a bear how's that okay
these gummy bears are more of a treat
for me to have during the day of work
this will make me die guys they're gummy
bears better than the alcohol they're
agreed no thing I mean doesn't make you
feel like the warm bourbon feeling not
really good oh my god I'm so about it
yeah it tastes of tequila mmm does
anything like to be like tequila chasers
like this I would drink it all the time
I may have this feel done further I feel
like I'm liking what enemies try thrown
in your mouth
I was curious if that was like salt but
why don't we you know gummy and then
take this out yeah what for Cheers
mmm
[Music]
mmm-hmm tequila with a gummy chaser yep
it's closer there is a patron this
flavor into a margarita I would drink
that real fast but the shot itself yeah
I told you I love tequila I think this
is a good vessel right snack these are
delicious I feel like these have the
perfect blend of like they taste like a
gummy bear the way gummy very supposed
to taste like when they also taste like
champagne oh no those are really it's
like tart and flavor
I'm almost be scared to like have them
because I feel like I'd have 20 of them
and then I might end up wasted if there
is alcohol content they did its job that
is alcoholic candy cheers Cheers I like
the champagne more this is so good I'll
finish us we have to work we do have to
work I feel flushed
am I like going red am i sweating I know
right I haven't had lunch and I'm in my
little tipsy it might be a little tipsy
that's sad
[Music]
[Music]